So we get to ride in an
Uber with the Uber CEO.
Yeah, that'll be pretty cool.
Do you get special
treatment on the app?
I do not get special
treatment on the app.
I wish I did.
If we call an electric
car right now,
whose comes first,
yours or mine?
It's an open marketplace.
It depends.
You never know
who comes in first.
Alright, let's do it.
Let’s pick our destination.
You can see lots of options.
You can go Comfort Electric.
You can go Green.
There's like 10 options
here, right now.
More than 10 options.
A lot of options.
Are you at all worried about
overwhelming consumers?
You know, going green is
going to take some time.
And we want to give as
many choices to consumers
so that they can pick to go green
on their terms, the
way that they want.
But let's go Comfort Electric
since there are
two of us in the car.
Let’s do it.
Here's Hailey.
Hello.
Hi. How are you doing?
How are you?
I'm good.
What is Uber's current
carbon footprint?
It's pretty significant.
Generally, the footprint is based
on essentially all
the miles driven.
We completed 2 billion
trips this last quarter.
And we've got to do
everything that we can
in order to reduce that footprint.
And we’ve committed
that by 2030 in the US,
and Europe, and Canada,
we're going to be all-electric.
And by 2040, we're going to
be electric all over the world.
That's an ambitious target.
Uber wants to cut
emissions entirely.
So for this ride-hailing giant,
that means getting to total
electrification, which would be
nothing short of a green miracle.
It's all part of the company's
sustainability agenda
called Go-Get Zero.
The goal is to go electric
and create the incentives
for drivers to go electric
as quickly as possible
and riders to pick electric as well.
So the smart charging
technology is allowing
drivers to know when
and where to charge,
to feel safe to get
routes that are efficient.
Then on the rider side,
is actually a feature for you
to see how much you're saving
in terms of emissions.
So when you get that Green car
or when you get
that Comfort Electric,
we’ll show you how much
you're helping out
the environment,
how many emissions
you're saving.
We have to get
that flywheel together.
We need drivers
to choose electric.
And then we're going to put more
and more electric options
in front of consumers as well.
How much more does
it cost to ride Electric?
If you're taking Green,
actually, it's the same
exact price as an UberX.
So are you taking the hit on that?
Or does the driver
take the hit on that?
Where does that cost?
We take the hit.
So we've said that we are
investing $800 million
in the transition to electric.
And we've got to make it
economically sensible
for drivers.
So for example, our take rate
on Electric rides is lower.
Because right now, generally,
EVs cost more than
combustion engines.
So I asked my Uber driver today
if he would switch to electric
and he said absolutely not.
He said the grid's not ready.
Mhmm.
What about the range anxiety?
What about the time
it takes to charge
when you could be driving?
You could be making money.
Yeah, those are real issues.
And I do think that as
it relates to charging,
we're introducing now smart
charge and routing technology.
How does that work?
What it does is when you
go out and start driving
based on your earnings
opportunity in the city,
we will identify
smart locations
for you to charge.
We’ll tell you when
you should charge.
Because even the charging
costs go up and down
on a daily basis or based
on different locations.
And another really cool
technology that we're
introducing is actually
smart routing as well.
We use AI algorithms so that if,
let's say you're at a 25%
charge or a 30% charge,
we won't send you
on a really long trip.
But we're not going to
send you on a trip
that is in a charging desert.
We're going to make sure that
there are plenty
of chargers around.
Time to charge up.
Alright, yes it is.
Does the charge time bother you?
Honestly, it does.
Yeah.
It's different.
It's something to get used to.
I don't like waiting too long
before I have to go.
Why did you buy a Tesla?
The pricing.
Like with gas right
now, it’s so expensive.
I come from spending
$400 a week
to spending $150 a week.
And that's a major deal,
especially when it
comes to budgeting.
Do you think Uber’s
treating drivers right?
I think they should be
able to pay a little more.
I think the benefits
should be better.
Like what?
Like health care, paid time off,
just regular benefits that,
you know, every other job gets.
The biggest obstacle is getting
all of these independent parties,
all of these companies,
all of these governments
and then consumers
to work together
in a way for a single goal,
which is electrification.
So we're saying, hey, let's as Uber,
we should take a lead
in electrification.
And in the end, it's good
business to go green.
Right.
San Francisco still hasn't
recovered from the pandemic.
What are Uber levels?
Well, when we look at
San Francisco in terms of
Uber and how it's come
back pre-pandemic,
San Francisco honestly
is pretty low.
On a global basis
in terms of trips,
we're well above
pre-pandemic level.
We're going through
a particularly difficult time
but never bet against
the tech sector
and never bet against
San Francisco coming back.
Well I hope you're right,
because it's my home too.